if you're a gamer who frequents the
purple rabbit hole that is twitch TV you
might look at eSports as a team affair a
fairy tale ending for gamers who harness
the power of synergy to compete at the
highest level and make a living from
their hobby
[__] you League I show you a lot yes
that was supposed to be the
inspirational clip as many of us know
the path to the big money contracts the
bright lights of the stage and the bro
hugs in analyst confetti showers is
paved by thousands of hours spent in
front of a screen but that's the peak of
competitive play it's unlikely you
witnessed the journey most of these
stars underwent to get there but you
have experienced the climb yourself a
seemingly futile lonely trek a spiritual
ascent that to some might even appear
masochistic of course the treacherous
oftentimes infuriating paths that I'm
talking about is solo queue so I need
two more wins lost the next one need
three lost will you be killed that's
what you did
I just had to cut the amount of times
I've been enslaved a-about a bucket
times I'm just like yo wassup
so we're did this ranking ladder that we
formed a love-hate relationship with
come from well competitive matchmaking
actually dates back about as far as the
early 1990s and one of the first titles
that featured an online multiplayer mode
was doomed often heralded as the
original bar setter for FPS but as
innovative as Doom was in 1993 its
method of enabling multiplayer was
actually pretty archaic the game's
readme file contained instructions on
how to properly share IP addresses with
the person you wanted to play with which
was a little advanced for your average
gamer in 1993
anyway after dooms successfully laid the
groundwork for player versus player in
shooters heed software saw that the next
natural step in the genre was a more
organized competitive experience which
ultimately led to the release of quake
quake is a truly three-dimensional
simulation of combat
quake was the first FPS to release with
multiplayer directly out of the box
allowing players to add dedicated server
addresses to an in-game address book
that being said it was still a battle
trying to find IPS so a lot of gaming
clans would store multiplayer
information on third-party websites to
facilitate matchmaking as the game
became more popular and its community
group third-party applications like
queue spy later game spy began to emerge
making it far easier for players to
browse servers and locate matches people
were finally able to play against each
other and it was great quick is carnage
carnage is good well aside from the fact
that there was no gauge for how good you
actually were the absence of a
leaderboard system was the missing
ingredient from the competitive online
gaming experience in software recognized
the demand for that following quakes
launched which they then followed up
with quake world
it's just quake with better network play
it has a few nicer features where the
status is changed it has persistent user
accounts where your ranks are tracked
through everything that the gameplay is
exactly what it is right now
quake world's ranking system
incorporated an overall frag count for
players
frags per minute and longest
uninterrupted quake game among other
stats while quake world was an
innovative glimpse into the future for
competitive gaming it still didn't help
players fully understand how they
stacked up against one another but the
answer to this question eventually
surfaced in the early 2000s with the
introduction of matchmaking ranked
systems major titles like Warcraft 3 the
Frozen Throne and Halo 2 blazed a trail
for the popularization of ranked online
multiplayer establishing number based
tiers which reflected a player's
capability within the overall community
these gradings became badges of honor or
brands of shame for gamers and set the
tone for the rank obsessed culture that
persists to this day but the ways we
track those rankings have changed some
games adopted an old chess ranking
system developed by a Hungarian American
physicist named arm pad AEL
that can't be right Oh Arpad elo anyway
the elo system assigns a rating to each
participant before a match based on
their game history that rating is then
altered based on the ranking of their
opponent and the outcome of the match
this way players who are underdogs
heading into a match are less impacted
by a negative outcome that said the elo
system despite its benefits in
individual focus games like Starcraft
and Street Fighter is not necessarily
ideal for team-based eSports because if
you lose a coin flip and get a player
who is just doesn't feel like pain it's
it's a loss I guess I can say one person
can lose your game but one person can't
win your game in League of Legends
though you're a low number is hidden the
current ranking model is based on tiers
they range from bronze to challenger and
your path through the ladder is
influenced by your élow whether you're a
basement dwelling scrub or an LCS
hopeful we all play on the same
schoolyard and although not everyone
agrees with their personal ranking the
only way to improve it is to throw
yourself back into the queue sound good
and as frustrating as the slippery rungs
ladder might be the true test of
soloqueue lies not just in ascending it
but in remaining seen while doing so
every game I literally pop off I'll
carry I'll smash my lane I'll shock all
I'll give us the exact ways to win and
people still like their head literally
headless chickens they just run it down
okay Blizzard explain to me how this
hook lands all you guys [__] do is
you go to read it all day is it ad carry
why can't I be the best of team fighting
all right I believe it now catch you
guys later Gigi's [__] this game I'm out
of here everybody could suck my [__]
wiener and the best at laning and the
best at 1v1 and the best late game in
early game in mid game I'm about to die
guys I shot in 64 64 thank you for the
sub so frustrating dude it's so [__]
frustrating the place soloqueue holds in
the eSports era is pretty ironic we've
got all these built out team eSports but
the only way to make it to the top of
the ladder is to sit alone at your
computer and tilt off the face of the
earth until it happens it's in that
toxic mosh pit that you must rely upon
your team to help you get where you want
to be and that can be difficult when you
keep being put in matches with a team oh
one trick as your ad carry or when some
jackass loses your team go round by
throwing a frag grenade into the hostage
worth or having to turn another blind
eye to another teammate trying to play
techies - any success again or when one
of your teammates is more interested in
being toxic in quick chat than making
important saves and don't even get me
started on overwatch but these Genji and
Hanzo maids upset I [__] love this
[__] yeah
more agitated
it's very angry like a Russian bear can
you imagine a better I'm walking in the
winter by someone he saw hanging and
he's like oh I will kill you know like
tiny rabbit anyways
[Music]